[Music]
okay so so now we'll go on to side
control okay and uh again starting with
Discovery learning okay you want to keep
your weight on this on this person uh
you don't want to put your weight on the
mat so to to do that you really want to
think of uh posting on him and not on
your hands or your elbows or stuff like
that okay so this first
exercise is I'm just going to get my
lower legs off the mat and all my
weights on him and second concept is
wherever your grips are whatever you're
doing with them you don't you don't
bring him up into you you don't lift him
up off the ground okay and it's your
elbows that are controlling him so even
if I'm here my elbows are controlling
his body in here if I'm here like this
this elbows here this elbows here is
controlling okay not my hands pulling in
okay uh and that way you can always let
your hands be ready to post and things
like that if you need to okay so here
here this is just the first drill and
you just relax and then he feels the
weight so you start here on your knees
he can he's the judge of what he feels
how much weight that is and then I'm
going to use the balls of my feet and
take my legs off and just relax on on
him and he should feel a weight increase
okay do you yes sir okay so we'll try
that uh Discovery L you learn to use the
balls of your feet so for
example you shouldn't ever be like that
okay if your leg if your knees aren't
near him you're on the balls of your
feet feet makes sense okay so that
that's what we're doing right now and
I'm just laying
down okay next Discovery learning is the
same thing we'll combine that
exercise uh and when we come off our
knees we want to make sure that our feet
are wider than our shoulders our hip
area so I would don't want to be like
this it's easy to to roll me okay you
can try that it's easy to lose balance
but when you're wide like this you can
be as heavy and uh he tries to roll and
you you're posting on that foot to help
reinforce things okay second Discovery
learning so the first exercise here is
you'll go narrow and he'll bridge and
roll you and you'll feel you'll lose it
and the next one is you you're wider
than your shoulders and you'll go and
you'll feel that resistance okay and
then the next Discovery learning
exercise is the point of no return so
your line of gravity can't be on the
other side of his spine I can't be over
here or I'm easily rollable this way
okay
so it's best it's ideal if your line of
gravity is just on your side of his
spine line so when he tries to roll he
feels all the weight of your body if he
comes back towards you he'll feel the
post of your legs okay so we'll try
those two
okay so don't confuse the discovery
learning with how you would address what
he's doing and how you deal with it and
and and what you want to do okay the
concept is wait on him okay uh have a
good base use your elbows to control
don't pull them up towards you watch
your point of no return okay you'll do
different things with your knees whether
one leg's bent both legs are bent uh
whether you even remain inside control
Etc okay uh some things to note uh feet
up knees up that's a trained response so
if you go back to your training you
always started like that right okay also
frames frames are are a trained response
that it takes a long time to learn how
to do proper frames okay um when we were
doing the mount
exercise we didn't really pay attention
to your legs so but be ready um if you
see the knees up and if you see frame
framing you the person is trained okay
uh so let's do one where he has his legs
down and he's got no frames okay makes
sense it's not uncommon so he doesn't
know elbow knee Escape all that kind of
stuff he he'll basically keep using his
arms is what he's going to do okay so if
that's the case then uh we can come up
and we get uh head and arm control over
here and we can stay here in this in
this position is one that you can do
okay is the the arm is dead you'll be
pushing with that with that arm and
you're just holding here and you just
start that fatigue cycle like that okay
anything he starts trying to punch you
with you can just hide your head you
still got the pin and you can just hang
out there okay so really simple one for
somebody who's not very train same thing
is not train okay and if you if you want
you can take this other arm and get it
more under more control so I'm over here
like that I'll push it out this way okay
and now I'm sitting I'm pinning this arm
here and I'm just sitting here okay so
one more time I'm here like that my
weight is on him weight is on you still
right I don't cross the point of no
return and I kind of pass it over here
and trap it under my shin like this okay
and same thing he tries to p push and
I'm just using my weight keeping my
elbows doing the controlling and keeping
my face uh protected from
strikes
okay so I'm not here I pass it we can go
to mouth okay so if we want I'll come on
knee on belly and I kind of push
everything this way I'm going to make
sure that arm doesn't go back down
to block me so I'm here and my whole
body stretches you do you feel that go
for okay and then I'm in and I kept the
arm on the right
side you see okay so I kept the arm on
the right side and then we're in our
Mount
techniques if you want okay and you have
this pin and you have the other arm pin
now you can work your radio
and you can always Dismount if you want
to or you can take it into the gift R we
do it one more
time head and arm control F Bo here
stretch him out to bring that arm up
bring the other arm into him you can now
pass and you should recognize all your
mou techniques from here
okay all right so now we start getting
someone a little more trained you see is
legs are up and he's going to try to
frame on you
okay we're here again weight is on his
chest you're not going to get away with
not controlling his hips so we'll bring
our knees in okay my knee is near his
hip over here I'm still going to try to
work for the head Arm Control but I'm
aware my elbows
okay um but my weight is still on him
and I'm not across the point of no
return
okay and the first one we'll do is he
starts pushing with this hand okay he's
pushing with that hand we pass it over
okay and we're in this position over
here I'll come across same exact way
and I'll push his legs this way so I
don't risk that half guard okay then you
have the same Mount techniques that you
have
okay so one more
time again if he's going to flare his
elbow then you you already have it okay
and you have it just fine
okay you work in here
so I guess that would be a first one he
makes the mistake of having a bad frame
you you're going to get it okay so his
elbow's
tight and he's trying to push
here he goes to push a pass and then
on push his legs
down then you're on okay then you
already have arm cross
body and you have all your mount
[Music]
all right so again the first one is if
you can get it you're already there you
got it okay boom pass it next one he
pushes pass it okay well once I get this
if he's got a good frame on the other
side and he starts pushing on that frame
go ahead then I don't want to come up
first okay so if he starts to push on
this arm here he's trying to
push so he pushes and I'll just roll it
this way you'll smash it and you'll come
back down when you come back down bring
your elbow make sure it's inside your
knee and then the arm is smash is
smashed in there so try to push with it
now doesn't have the leverage okay so
again one more time a good
frame you'll feel feel him push when he
pushes roll your hip then bring your
knee outside your elbow once you're
there now you can go on and do the same
technique okay and again on this
side bring your knee up and you C that
arm as well
okay let's try it
so either I manually walked this
out or he pushed on me and I passed it
okay now he's on the other arm so he
push he's trying to get some space there
and again I'll roll
over the wrist and then lock it in with
the
knee sometimes though they're really
strong and they're really using their
elbow okay so he's using his elbow you
won't be able to get to the other side
of that so when he goes to push we'll
come underneath this way okay we come
underneath and we trap over here go back
and hold I'm going to hold on the S grip
here
okay so
again we go I got that his elbow's doing
it I'm going to go underneath
this way push across here under my chest
and then come up to the S RP here okay
you feel it yes sir you're posting here
and your base is spread out here your
weight is still on this chest and you're
not over the point of no return and
you're just hanging out in this arm trap
try to move your
arms and you start the fatig CLE
on okay now there's no reason why he
pushed here
first or he didn't push here first
before I got that arm isolated okay so
maybe we're here and he's already trying
to drive space there okay again if he's
with his palm on me and he tries to
drive space then you just do that first
move and then you can work the arm
isolation on the other side if he's with
his
elbow wait let me get in position he's
in his elbow and he starts to dry then
I'll come in here to get to K aama
straight and isolate that arm behind me
this way okay I can anchor this
here and I can control this arm here
okay that'll give me my free hand on the
radio
so
again early on he pushed on the elbow
and I'll come this
way this
way anchor my grip on my on myself here
in this case I was able to smash it
underneath this arm right there and
he'll get it out eventually okay and
I'll just tuck and protect here this way
that's the first
variation here
he pushes up I know I'm not going to
pass that so I came underneath I'm over
here he starts to push on that neck I
pass that one over here and then I come
over the top and I'm holding it here
okay and for my size I'm having to use
the S grip if you can get that Gable
grip go to the Gable grip or even just
lock on your forearm all that kind of
stuff works but make it tight so that he
can't get out
okay so you have all your Dismounts from
the mount so you could advance to the
Mount and then if you want you could
Dismount to go to your Force options but
you can you also have Dismounts from
here okay so the first one will work on
either I isolated that arm and passed it
across me or he pushed on me and I
passed it across me here okay so once I
pass it across I'll just smash it
underneath me and I'm going to come
around it this
way once I'm on this side then I can
clear myself and come out with a force
option towards the head
Direction one more
time however you got there it got across
I'll push it under my chest and I use my
arms all my weights on that right time
okay and then once I'm there now I can
push up
and come out with a for stion okay let's
try just pushing on this arm I go
underneath you could be in any one of
those other positions but you'll
eventually you want to Dismount this leg
comes over
here you're on it already push
down
up this m again
push boom boom on all my weights on
there boom towards the
head okay try